bonjour vous avez déniché sur youtube il
n'y a pas très longtemps et pour
l'instant le nombre d'abonnés
n'augmentent pas je vais vous dire dans
cette vidéo comment avoir vomi le
premier abonné assez facilement vous
allez voir une fois qu'on a mis en place
les bonnes techniques c'est pas si
difficile que ça et ça peut même aller
très vite
de plus en plus de chengguan jour sur
youtube et il est extrêmement difficile
de réussir ce passage avec vous toutes
mes astuces mes meilleures techniques
pour gagner des vues des abonnés et
enfin réussir sur youtube à ce qu avez
vous à ma chaîne est activé la cloche
pour ne manquer aucune vidéo
quand on commence sur youtube on est
souvent très rapidement frustré parce
qu'on ne voit pas son nombre d'abonnés
augmenter rapidement avoir ses cent
premiers abonnés ces deux sens et 500
premiers abonnés peut paraître très
difficile et alors les mille abonnés
c'est le graal le point inatteignable et
pourtant si on met en place les bonnes
pratiques
on peut arriver très facilement aux 1000
premiers abonnés je vais vous dire tout
de suite comment gagner vaut mille
premiers abonnés et vous allez voir avec
un peu de travail un peu de méthode on y
arrive très facilement question du jour
combien avez-vous d'abonnés sans votre
chaîne youtube pourquoi selon vous
est-ce que vous n'arrivez pas progresser
quels sont les points qui bloquent
est ce que vous arrivez à les identifier
ou alors est-ce que vous êtes vraiment
perdu et vous voyez pas du tout ce qui
bloque
mettez moi tout ça en commentaire je
prenais le temps d'y répondre et puis
j'essaierai de vous aider au maximum la
toute première chose à savoir c'est de
publier régulièrement si vous publiez
régulièrement il votre contenu de
qualité vous serez référence à bhl c'est
extrêmement important aujourd'hui sur
youtube pour pouvoir effectivement
progresser gagner des vues tout
simplement être positionnés dans les
résultats de recherche et dans les
suggestions de publier régulièrement ça
c'est youtube qu'il exige c'est la
machine il faut la nourrir
mais on paie pas la nourrir n'importe
comment il faut absolument publier un
contenu de qualité c'est à dire qu'il
faut vous trouviez votre niche que vous
ayez des choses à dire que vous ciblez y
ait une population des gens qui ont des
problématiques et vous puissiez les
résoudre ou alors que vous leur apportez
la formation dont ils ont besoin que
vous bien que si vous publiez un contenu
qui est intéressant et qui est toujours
dans la même niche qui répondent à la
même problématique sur différents points
les gens reviendront parce qu'ils ont un
intérêt du coup vous aurez votre
compteur de vue qui va augmenter parce
que vous répondez à des choses que les
gens recherchent et dès lors que vous
avez plein
vidéo qui sont toutes cohérente vous
pourrez convertir vos vues en abonnés
les gens s'abonneront tout simplement
pour revenir voir votre contenu et pour
être informé des nouveautés
posez vous la question lorsque vous
regardez vos vidéos youtube lorsque vous
suivez des chaînes pour quelles raisons
avez-vous vous abonner la plupart du
temps c'est parce qu'on est vraiment fan
d'une personne ou alors que la chaîne
répond vraiment à notre problématique et
vos spectateurs ne déroge pas à la règle
c'est exactement la même chose s'ils
s'abonnent à votre chienne c'est qu'ils
ont un intérêt point très important ne
fait pas de cette force ne dit pas aux
gens c'est tu ta bonne à ma chaîne jeu
l'abonné la tienne ça ne sert
strictement à rien c'est un signe
négatif ça veut dire que personne ne
s'abonne probablement une chaîne et que
le conflit n'est pas très intéressant
vous aurez des abonnés inactifs et ça
c'est le pire
vous avez tout de suite allé consulter
ma fille pour voir les 10 bonnes astuces
qui marche quand on débute sur youtube
ça pourra vous aider
concentrez vous sur votre niche et
trouver les mots clés qui sont
pertinents une fois que vous avez
identifié les mots clés qui sont
pertinents il faut vous travaillez sur
cette thématique et rien sur cette
thématique
on ne se dissipa on reste uniquement
concentré sur sa thématique ça c'est la
clé du succès est d'autant plus quand on
débute une fois qu'on a débuté et qu'on
a des millions d'abonnés
on peut se permettre de faire deux
choses certains partiront d'autres
resteront mais quoi qu'il se passe vous
aurez une base de fans qui vous
permettra d'avoir des vues aujourd'hui
le but c'est de se créer une audience
c'est d'avoir des abonnés il faut donc
être cohérent et toujours dans la même
thématique
concentrez vous sur votre recherche
future aller taper dans la barre de
recherche en eau les mots clés qui vous
paraissent pertinents ça vous souhaitez
des expressions clés sur lesquels il
faut travailler aujourd'hui pour être vu
et pour gagner des fans et pour être
découvert vous avez deux points
essentiels le premier c'est la
suggestion soit sur la page d'accueil
sur des thématiques soit sur la barre
latérale
dès lors des spectateurs on voir des
vidéos qui traite de votre thématique
vous allez être suggérées mais pour être
suggérée il faut que youtube comprennent
bien votre thématique comprennent vos
mots clés et puissent ensuite vous
positionner tout une stratégie aussi
pour référencer pour être positionné
vous invite à aller voir sa fiche là
pour comprendre comment mettre en place
une bonne stratégie qui marche il faut
vous soyez cohérent une fois de plus sur
le titre de votre vidéo sur la
description de vidéos sur les taxes de
votre vidéo et sur vos miniature c'est
hyper important
d'ailleurs en parlant de miniatures je
vous invite à aller voir cette fiche
pour savoir comment faire votre
miniatures et vous allez voir c'est
extrêmement facile avec un outil gratuit
et sans logis
une fois votre contenu tant ligne aller
sur les réseaux sociaux publiée sur
votre page sur twitter sur instagram et
surtout les réseaux sociaux allez sur
des forums qui correspondent à votre
niche ça vous permettra d'être découvert
et puis d'augmenter vos nombreux de vue
moi au début quand j'ai commencé sur
youtube je faisais un petit blog quelque
peu une intéressant je ne progressais
pas et je me suis ensuite poser les
bonnes questions savoir comment faire
comment progresser
comment captiver une audience et puis
comment trouver des sujets qui
pourraient intéresser
je me suis concentré suivre sur une de
mes passions l'high tech gelé développer
à fond j'ai trouvé les bons mots clés
les bonnes expressions clés j'ai compris
comment fonctionne et youtube et comment
fonctionne l algorithme j'ai pu
travailler meetic mais vignette mes
descriptions mes taxes et ma chaîne a
augmenté très rapidement et j'ai gagné
très très rapidement mais 1000 premiers
abonnés si ça m'est arrivé à moi ça vous
arriverez à vous trouvez votre niche
soyez cohérent ne vous dispersez pas
publier régulièrement du contenu de k
lite et mettez en place la bonne
stratégie de référencement et vous
verrez ça marchera votre compteur
augmenté sans abonnés 200 500 vous allez
passer des paliers ça va vous réjouir et
vous aurez très rapidement vaut mille
premiers abonnés et vous allez voir le
plus dur sur youtube c'est de lancer la
machine c'est d'amorcer la pompe
une fois que ça commence vous aller
grossir vos premières vidéos commencent
à vous apporter des vues continuerons à
vous en apporter les suivantes également
et après ça ira de plus en plus vite
c'est exponentiel
ne vous découragez pas croyant vous
travailler correctement est vraiment
tous les points soit lignée qualité
régularité référencement une stratégie
qui marche et vos compteurs vont
augmenter extrêmement vite
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
qu'elle vous a plu mais des mois un joli
pouces n'hésitez pas à me laisser en
commentaire bondir quels sont vos
problématiques et puis de quoi parle
votre chaîne ou est ce que vous êtes
aujourd'hui en nombre d'abonnés
abonnez-vous à la chaîne fassois un plus
en plus de vidéos pour vous aider à
réussir sur youtube et pour mettre en
place la stratégie qui marche
merci beaucoup et quand à moi et je vous
dis à très bientôt salut
[Musique]